Anita's Idol is a train driver for
Deutsche Bahn her training took eight
months she used to be a saleswoman and
now she's driving one of Berlin's
commuter trains from here I control 160
meters of rolling steel I would never
have thought it possible in her previous
job Annetta was given one short term
contract after the other until one day
she found herself unemployed I was on
the verge of giving up I received one
rejection after the other despite good
references and never being out of work
for very long then my advisor at the Job
Center suggested the Berlin rail network
she was desperate for new work and
deutsche bahn urgently needed new staff
and not just train drivers the firm has
to employ up to 10,000 new staff every
year for years the firm cut its
workforce to save costs one of the main
reasons was to prepare for a stock
market flotation but that plan is now on
ice
this way us would have the railway cut
jobs for a long time and now it's
expanding its workforce
what happened below the workforce is
being expanded but mostly we need to
fill existing jobs that are opening up
because of retirement that's five to
seven thousand jobs every year thousand
dollars colleagues who were with us for
30 to 40 years are leaving
my sister's car but they need to be
replaced and we're looking for successes
what forgive it enough for four years
Deutsche bonds management should have
been preparing for the inevitable
challenges of an aging workforce did you
just forget I can only tell you what has
happened since 2009 when I took over
this post that this year the office how
do you rate the work of your predecessor
they did a good job
and so Deutsche Bahn is looking for
thousands of electricians office and
service staff the firm is using the
Internet to recruit new personnel the
man in charge is OVA bio for many years
the company neglected to train enough
staff now social networks like Facebook
are being used to help fill the gap
we've isn't as fair we know that young
people students live part of their lives
on Facebook and they don't look to the
traditional media channels we know that
this target group watches very little
television these issues actually can
reach them very well through the
internet is your wound a bond with your
neck honey innovation Deutsche Bahn is
also turning to older jobseekers Netta's
Idol now earns about 2,500 euros each
month before deductions and taxes almost
twice the amount she earned in her
previous job can you imagine doing it
for the rest of your life if someone
came to me and said I have a great job
for you in wholesale or more
or whatever I would say no I'm here and
I plan to stay here it's been yes bloody
here
Aneta zidle is safe and her job still
Deutsche Bahn is searching for train
drivers all over Germany another 800
vacancies need to be filled